regisseur scott kellner aber zu die
firma sich seit vielen jahren also
kürzer beiderseitig glaubt april
perspektive momentan ist schwierig wird
sagte man kann natürlich sicher
irgendwas anders manchmal von baustellen
wir wochen designer wo kann ich rufe die
uns glücklich machen weil wir wissen
dass mit die konzerte in warschau war
das genau dieses aus mir machen und nur
zu hause sitzen und wir hoffen dass kay
one weiter sondern riester was müsste
das problem sei befanden arbeitslos wenn
man die augen wohin ist sondern wenn man
einfach blue chip oder auf erlebt wo man
nichts dafür kennen und da was kommt es
weitergeht
also ist wird wahrscheinlich erst weiter
gewinnen wirklicher impfstoff preis oder
wenn es medikamente gibt das ist mein
job als schülerlotsen und sich damit der
bislang tagesablauf wieder neugierig und
irgendwann sind wo ich so etwas macht
das sinn gibt dann noch wie sie uns
unsere firma kurz an einer seinen
streifen job auf dem land lassen
aber ansonsten gesagt es werde dazu bis
nächsten sommer durchhalten hoffentlich
ja herr keller ist sicherheitsmann und
hat bei konzerten für recht und ordnung
gesorgt aber tatsächlich das ist
natürlich jetzt auch wirklich alles
eingebrochen
tatsächlich glaube das
sicherheitspersonal wird weiterhin
gebraucht aber eben zurzeit nicht bei
konzerten wie sehen sie diesen fall
das ist in der tat so wir haben
natürlich eine ganze reihe von völlig
neuen betätigungsfeldern das sind auch
die bewachung situation im zusammenhang
mit der einhaltung von carola regeln
das wird ja vielfach jetzt in
gastrobetrieben wird das genutzt oder
auch bei supermärkten beispielsweise
oder auch bei behörden da ist jetzt eine
erhöhte bedarf gegeben aber das fängt
leider nicht dass auch was sozusagen
wegfällt
zum glück sind diese kurzarbeiter regeln
verlängert worden
bis zum in das ende des nächsten jahres
hinein so dass es da ein bisschen mehr
luft gibt ein bisschen mehr puffer gibt
ob das dann tatsächlich ausreicht müssen
wir tatsächlich sehen ob das die
unternehmen rettet es wird mit
sicherheit noch eine ganze reihe an
pleite-verfahren leider geben und aber
das ist zumindest eine möglichkeit eine
zeitlang zu überwintern
es stellen wir uns mal vor ich wäre
kurzarbeiter und würde jetzt quasi zu
hause sitzen wie herr kellner eben was
wären so anzeichen dass es für mich
vielleicht in den regulären job nicht
wieder zurückgeht naja also wenn das
unternehmen trotzdem also trotz dieser
kurzarbeit gar nicht weiter existiert
weil beispielsweise die aufträge
komplett wegfallen
und da überhaupt nichts mehr passieren
kann oder langfristig irgendwelche
zahlungs verbindlichkeiten nicht mehr
eingehalten werden können
denn die anderen verbindlichkeiten
laufen ja komplett weiter beispielsweise
mieten da hatten wir also gewerbemieten
da hatten wir ja vor einiger zeit zu
über den vorübergehenden zeitraum hatten
wäre eine möglichkeit geben die
zahlungen zurückzustellen
das baut sich dann auf und wenn man dann
eben merkt dass die aufträge weg bleiben
und dass die schuldenlast immer größer
wird für die unternehmen dann wird es
eng